j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public des balles actu sur la
pénurie de certains médicaments en
France les principales organisations de
de pédiatres et d'infectiologue alerte
sur le manque d'amoxicilline c'est l'un
des antibiotiques tout simplement les
plus utilisés pour les enfants on va
expliquer cette situation on va tenter
aussi de trouver des solutions avec nos
invités mais d'abord ça reportage que je
vous propose sur un autre médicament le
paracétamol la relocalisation de sa
production est en route avec
l'entreprise c'est coince Audrey bettaz
c'est dans ce centre de recherche
francilien que tout recommence depuis
maintenant deux ans plus d'une centaine
d'ingénieurs et de docteurs en chimie
oeuvres pour que la production du
paracétamol revienne sur le sol français
on est en train de faire une synthèse
d'un nouveau principe actif alors quand
on veut relocaliser un principe actif
comme le parestamol il n'essaie de faire
l'innovation on ne peut réussir cette
relocalisation en termes de coût de
qualité d'emprunter environnementale
qu'en y mettant de l'innovation et en
repensant l'ensemble du procédé de
synthèse du principe actif conséquence
d'un constat inquiétant en 2020 au plus
fort de la crise du covid la France se
rend compte qu'elle n'a plus la main sur
le principe actif de l'antidouleur le
plus prescrit au monde le paracétamol
comme 80% des médicaments il est produit
en Asie les pharmaciens doivent alors
rationner les ventes tout le monde a vu
durant cette crise que des médicaments
qui paraissaient usuels n'étaient plus
produits en France et en Europe
tout le monde l'a vécu nous lancerons
une initiative de relocalisation de
certaines productions critiques on
pourra par exemple
pleinement reproduire
conditionner distribuer du paracétamol
en France
l'un des leaders de la pharma tricolore
s'engage à relever le défi avec le
soutien financier de France relance mais
il faut maintenant tout repenser pour
dépasser les freins du passé en France
la dernière chaîne de production a été
fermée par le groupe Audi a en 2008 pour
deux raisons majeures le manque de
compétitivité et la pollution générée
par la fabrication du principe actif il
va falloir faire mieux relocaliser une
production en Europe et très compliquée
déjà parce que il faut assurer une
compétitivité alors que la structure de
coût de l'Europe est bien évidemment
supérieur à la structure de coût de
l'Asie par exemple et deuxièmement il
faut pour relocaliser il faut innover et
trouver développer des procédés qui
soient moins impactant pour
l'environnement et on n'y arrive pas
toujours ici le Paris est réussi la
nouvelle recette de seaquence devrait
permettre de supprimer les polluants re
dans l'eau et de diviser par 5 les
émissions de CO2 le groupe débute
maintenant la construction d'un site qui
produira à terme 10 000 tonnes de
paracétamol avec 50 emplois directs à la
clé comme un symbole il verra le jour à
Roussillon à l'endroit même où la
dernière usine de paracétamol a fermé il
y a 15 ans
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Laurence harribet bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
de la Gironde co-rapporter du rapport
d'information de la commission des
affaires européennes pour une Europe du
médicament au service des patients
Thierry hollow bonsoir bonsoir venu vous
êtes le président de merk France et
président du LEM c'est l'organisation
professionnelle des entreprises du
médicament Frédéric bizard bonsoir
bienvenue économiste spécialiste des
questions de protection sociale et de
santé vous êtes professeur d'économie
affiliés à le SCP Europe et auteur de ce
livre l'autonomie solidaire en santé la
seule réforme possible aux éditions
Michalon et Mathieu croissandeau
évidemment est resté à mes côtés est-ce
que c'est l'exemple à suivre on dit pour
commencer sur ce le reportage la
relocalisation du paracétamol Laurence
Harris
moi je dirais que c'est une solution en
trompe l'oeil pourquoi c'est pas en
relocalisant des médicaments qui sont
des médicaments plutôt de base que on va
retrouver la question la souveraineté
pharmaceutique de l'Europe je crois que
le problème est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça en fait bon je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre du
symbolique et c'est finalement c'est
très bien mais en fait nous dans le
rapport qu'on a travaillé avec Pascal
Greny avec qui j'ai travaillé en fait on
s'est intéressé à la pénurie on s'est
intéressé à la notion de médicaments
critique et il y a deux types de de
criticité il y a une criticité
industrielle et puis il y a une
criticité clinique et je crois qu'on
peut pas traiter les choses de la même
manière et puis il faudrait d'abord
cibler les médicaments dont on a le plus
besoin pour tout faire pour les
relocaliser il faudrait une définition
de du médicament critiques qu'on n'a pas
on l'a on a on est en train d'y
travailler au niveau européen à partir
de la définition
a priori française mais on n'a pas une
définition européenne et la pandémie
elle a démontré en effet ce qu'on savait
déjà depuis quelques dizaines d'années
en fait parce que la souveraineté
sanitaire de l'Europe on l'a perdu
quasiment en 20 ans puisque aujourd'hui
80 % des des substances pharmaceutiques
viennent de l'extérieur et 40% des
médicaments finis sont produits dans les
pays tiens et
européens les chiffres européens et on
est passé en fait on n'est pas on est
passé de 80 de 20% à 80% en l'espace de
20 ans donc c'est que c'est pas c'est
pas un phénomène qui est qui est récent
et qui est dû aussi à la spécificité de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui est une
industrie à la fois qui demande beaucoup
d'innovations de recherche et
développement donc qui demande des des
conditions pour pouvoir des conditions
d'attractivité autour de ces exigences
là et puis c'est une industrie qui est
très Mondi et donc si on prend pas ça en
compte en fait on a une vision un petit
peu basique et restrictive vous avez
très bien posé les enjeux du débat je
vous en remercie on va on va reprendre
un certain nombre des arguments que vous
que vous venez de développer mais alors
je vais rester tirer au lot sur une
question temporalité parce que
finalement si je reviens sur l'histoire
de cette
relocalisation de du paracétamol en
France entre la décision annoncée par le
président de la République et si tout va
bien l'ouverture la ligne de production
enfin la sortie des premières boîtes il
sera passé à les trois ans et demi
quatre ans je suis peut-être optimiste
en disant ça je vois votre on peut pas
aller plus vite quoi mais on peut pas
aller plus vite parce que il faut
construire l'usine il faut obtenir les
permis de construire ensuite il faut la
qualifier il faut qualifier le personnel
il faut obtenir les autorisations
réglementaires et je trouve que le
reportage donne très bien le challenge
de la realis de la relocalisation c'est
il faut faire ça de manière efficiente
en termes de coût pour avoir une marge
pour que cette entente usine ensuite
elle puisse vivre elle puisse embaucher
si pour la fermer deux ans après ça n'a
pas de c'est inutile et puis il faut
travailler sur l'impact environnemental
si on dit aujourd'hui on aimerait
relocaliser en France toute la matière
première des médicaments
il y a 12000 molécules dans la
pharmacopée donc on revient à ce que
disait c'est à dire 80% en gros sur mon
dossier ça des molécules elles viennent
d'ailleurs c'est ça si je simplifie quoi
comment faire alors que la plupart des
sites nécessitent une année
que la plupart des régions des
territoires ne souhaitent pas donc ça
nécessite un effort d'innovation comme
c'est montré dans le reportage pour
faire ça de manière éco-responsable et
donc s'opposera à l'arrivée la notion du
prix de revient industriel et de la
marge financière comme on ces
entreprises pour vivre si on reste avec
un prix des médicaments qui est planché
c'est intéressant l'acceptabilité vous
êtes en train de nous dire que grosso
modo dans les régions ou les ou les
villes où on voudrait
relocaliser il y aura une partie de la
population qui dira non ces vaisseaux
il y a un risque qui arrive avec un
projet innovant respectueux de
l'environnement et c'est là où est
l'avenir c'est pour ça que madame la
sénatrice disait il y a un vrai combat
qui est d'attirer quelque part les
molécules innovantes nouvelles pour
lequel aujourd'hui dans le process
industriel dès les premières étapes on a
cette réflexion
éco-responsable mais il y a un autre
sujet on parle beaucoup de relocaliser
mais évitons surtout de délocaliser on y
reviendra parce qu'il y a un risque il y
a notamment
un secteur qui souffre comme beaucoup
d'autres de la hausse du prix de
l'énergie et ça ça je vous donnera la
parole là-dessus évidemment Frédéric
bizat est-ce que la situation actuelle
ça concerne on l'a un peu évoqué dans la
première partie il y a pas que
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui qui
évidemment
à disparu du sol français ou du sol
européen mais si on fait le focus sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est quoi et
sur la France on produit trop de
médicaments finalement d'entrée de gamme
pas assez de médicaments qui demandent
de l'innovation c'est un peu ça le souci
oui on peut regarder sur une échelle
plus macroéconomique il y a les
industrialisations pharmaceutiques elle
est elle s'inscrit dans une des
indistralisation de la France plus
marquée c'est une industrialisations qui
est assez générale en Europe mais plus
marquée en France on était à 23% de PIB
il y a à peu près dans les années 90 on
a l'industrie à 13 points de PIB pour
industrie on a perdu à peu près 2
millions et demi d'emplois sur 30 ans
bon tout ça est assez général sur le
plan de la santé d'abord un beaucoup
politique de la part de Monsieur Macron
autour de ce doliprane je suis d'accord
avec madame la sénatrice tout ça n'a
aucun intérêt économique n'a aucun
intérêt pour la souveraineté nationale
mais mi-temps est très symbolique et
notamment
la souveraineté nationale c'est deux
choses c'est d'abord ça se fait à
l'échelle européenne sur la chose c'est
garantir le fait de disposer de des
médicaments qui sont consommés et
d'autre part de maîtriser les
technologies innovantes
et la France devrait se positionner sur
quel des deux axes probablement un peu
sur les deux mais surtout sur le
deuxième pourquoi parce qu'on a un
modèle social coûteux on peut toujours
demander en permanence de baisser les
coûts du travail mais on sera toujours
moins compétitif que beaucoup de pays
qui ont structurellement des coups de
production plus faible changer les
médicaments qu'on produit
à votre question que ça soit dans la
défense ce que l'on fait plutôt bien
parce qu'on est plutôt dans le haut de
gamme dans l'automobile ce qu'on fait
plutôt mal parce qu'on est plutôt sur le
bas de gamme et dans la santé où nous
étions parmi les pays les plus innovants
avant 2000 et nous avons raté le virage
des biotechnologies et maintenant raté
le virage de la génomique on l'a vu avec
la RN messager donc on se retrouve en
fait à produire majoritairement des
vieux produits donc avec le paracétamol
c'est un peu le c'est c'est aussi le
symbole de de nos échecs à produire les
pays les produits innovants alors on
peut dire c'est pas très grave mais ça
c'est 100 millions d'euros c'est
beaucoup de communication vous voyez on
en parle ce soir et la ressource elle
est rare comme le temps et la ressource
le temps est là donc je pense que
Monsieur l'Audi c'est ça met du temps
mais c'est justement parce qu'il y a une
inertie et parce qu'on travaille
toujours sur le moyen terme qu'il faut
prendre les bonnes décisions
stratégiques donc c'est très fortement
l'usine la plus importante à relocaliser
pour être plus performant dans les
produits de santé innovants demain très
honnêtement pas grand chose en matière
de de production moins de 10% des
produits innovants sont produits en
France aujourd'hui contre
30-35% en Allemagne par exemple pour
prendre un pays dernier point si on veut
l'industrie c'est lié avec la recherche
c'est lié aussi avec l'aval le système
de santé la crise de la recherche
médicale en France explique une partie
parce que l'élaboratoires vont en
général là où sont
trouvés les produits innovants et où il
y a un écosystème pas simplement la base
productive mais où il y a un écosystème
très attractif et c'est surtout ça qu'il
faut travailler en France alors je vais
vous redonner la parole évidemment mais
voudrais je reste encore un petit peu
sur l'histoire de cette
usine de paracétamol avec le maire de la
ville en Isère parce qu'il y avait une
usine en Isère il y a quelques années
c'était battu pour empêcher ça ça
fermeture il a il a croisé Emmanuel
Macron dans les allées du du Salon des
mers et des collectivités locales
aujourd'hui il a posté pour lui dire ça
j'ai travaillé pendant 40 ans sur cette
plateforme et je la connais bien et en
2009 on s'était battus contre l'affaire
la dernière unité de production de
paracétamol d'Europe on nous avait dit à
l'époque que ça coûtait moins cher
d'aller le fabriquer en Chine il a fallu
une pandémie pour que les gens se
rencontrent et notamment les autorités
pour qu'elles se rendent compte que
c'est utile de fabriquer du paracétamol
en France Thierry Hulot est-ce que
effectivement la pandémie profondément
change la donne dans votre relation avec
les pouvoirs publics sur la capacité à
effectivement relocaliser ou non choisir
les bons médicaments à produire en
France et en Europe je vais faire une
réponse presque Suisse en vous disant
oui et non d'accord oui parce que la
pandémie fait que tout le monde s'est
dit une industrie pharmaceutique forte
c'est une industrie stratégique et il
faut la renforcer et donc il y a eu
beaucoup d'annonces notamment
dans la filière stratégique lors du xis
pour renforcer cette industrie
avec un grand plan ma santé 2030 où
est-ce qu'on veut aller l'indépendance
sanitaire française j'y crois plus au
niveau européen et puis tous les ans à
l'automne on a le coup près du PLFSS
alors le qui appuie sur le
freinfinancement la sécurité sociale et
là vous avez été déçu le le dernier
session c'est pas d'être déçu c'est
est-ce qu'on se donne les moyens de
notre ambition est-ce qu'on veut que
demain les innovations thérapeutiques
qui arrivent qui vont être nombreuses
dans les années qui viennent soit en
premier à disposition des nos
concitoyens des patients français et ce
que demain on veut que les traitements
matures du quotidien qui existent depuis
des années mais qui sont indispensables
soient présents en France juste pour
mémoire au moment de la crise de la
covid la première crise
médicamenteuse qu'on a eue ce n'est pas
de pas avoir de vaccins on manquait de
curare dans les hôpitaux
et ça c'était dramatique comment on s'en
est sorti par une coopération
internationale en mutualisant les stocks
donc il y a un véritable état d'urgence
en ce qui concerne le médicament il y a
une ambition très forte il faut dépasser
le symbole parce que le symbole c'est
bien mais ça suffit pas et être cohérent
dans la durée et c'est là où il faut un
plan de financement pluriannuel et pas
un saucissonnage je ne connais personne
dans les maladies s'arrêtent au 31
décembre bien d'accord alors on va
continuer de d'évoquer des solutions
possibles mais je voudrais qu'on essaye
collectivement de répondre à la question
d'une pénurie qui concerne combien de
médicaments
avant de vous donner la parole sur sur
ce thème une réaction celle du sénateur
LR de la Vienne il est pharmacien il
s'appelle Bruno Belin c'était le 9
novembre au Sénat lors des questions au
Gouvernement la France est à sec
à sec d'argent à sec d’eau à sec
d'électricité à sec de gaz à sec de
nucléaire à sec de médecins et
maintenant à sec de certains médicaments
spasfon et gaviscon nous cherchons
amoxicilline et paracétamol aussi rare
que le pétrole en cette épidémie de
bronchiolite c'est dramatique ce sont
pourtant des médicaments matures peu
onéreux et essentiel tout au long de
l'année voilà qui pratique aussi la rime
dans ces questions de gouvernement vous
l'aurez remarqué je vous propose
d'accueillir en duplex Catherine Simonin
qui est administratif à France à sauce
santé vous portez la voix des usagers
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
notre invitation c'est un retour
d'expérience que je vous demande tout de
suite dans ce débat les signalements de
rupture de stock de médicaments
notamment on parlait des médicaments
critiques il y a ce qu'on appelle les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur vous vous ressentez une
augmentation de ces signalements
oui bien sûr d'abord il y a des
obligations réglementaires les
industriels doivent faire des plans de
prévention des pénuries et de gestion
des pénuries et les signalés à la NSM
dès qu'il y a une tension donc ça c'est
un progrès c'est réglementaire et c'est
suite à la feuille de route pour lutter
contre les pénuries qui a été mise en
place par le gouvernement et donc là on
est à on est passé par exemple de 1504
pénuries signalées en faisant tension de
pénurie pardon en 2019 à 2160
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on voit bien
effectivement la définition des
médicaments elle existe en France elle
n'existe pas en Europe c'est les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs et ces médicaments-là rentrent
dans cette obligation réglementaire
ensuite il y a eu aussi le décret sur
les stocks deux mois de stock et un mois
pour les non MITM c'est à dire les
autres médicaments comme le paracétamol
par contre l'amoxicilline les Antibi ce
sont des MITM et donc ils sont éligibles
à deux mois de stock sauf pour les
mauvais élèves quand il y a dans les
deux années précédentes des pénuries ils
doivent réaliser quatre mois de stock
c'est le cas pour l'amoxicilline et l'AS
ça n'a pas été réalisé aujourd'hui alors
des patients se retrouvent sans
médicament et c'est vraiment un enjeu
majeur que de lutter contre ce fléau et
je reviendrai vers vous évidemment un
peu plus tard dans le débat mais Thierry
Hulot voilà qu'est-ce qu'il en est
je suis pharmacien je travaille dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique le matin je
me lève parce que ma Vocation c'est
qu'impatient qui ait besoin d'un
traitement il est au moment où il faut
et je pense que c'est pas en disant il y
a des mauvais élèves qu'on va régler le
problème on a tous la même volonté c'est
de s'assurer qu'un patient et son
traitement c'est sûr factoriel c'est
très complexe et évidemment on est tous
d'accord là dessus mais alors je vais
vous demander d'être très précis sur
l'amoxicilline puisque
les les organisations de pédiatres et
d'infectiologues disent disent là on va
au devant dans quelques jours c'est leur
terme je de d'un grave problème de santé
publique en France alors l'amoxicilline
c'est pas produit en France c'est pas
produit en Europe il y a une
augmentation mondiale de la demande qui
n'a pas été vu anticipé il y a peu de
fabricants pourquoi
pourquoi il y a cette demande qui
augmente alors je ne connais pas la
prévision exacte dans le détail ce qu'on
voit c'est que pendant la période du
covid les confinements successifs ont
fait que des pathologies infectieuses du
quotidien ont plutôt diminué et que on a
mis du temps à relancer l'appareil
productif mais on a aussi du temps
à le prévoir et à le voir venir et le
temps industriel est un temps long ça
fait des mois que le LEM
qui regroupe toutes les industries
pharmaceutiques alertent les pouvoirs
publics sur ces risques alertent les
pouvoirs publics sur les conséquences de
l'inflation donc ça veut dire que les
stocks dont on parle c'était impossible
de les reconstituer si je comprends bien
c'est ça l'histoire alors si on prend ça
de manière générale quand on voit
qu'aujourd'hui avec l'inflation le coût
de l'aluminium quand vous ouvrez un
comprimé vous savez vous percez la
petite film protecteur d'aluminium plus
30%. mais au-delà du coup le délai de
livraison plus 40%. les cartons dans
lequel vous mettez vos comprimés
augmentation des coûts 50% augmentation
des livraison 150% donc vous êtes aussi
dépendant de vos fournisseurs et on sait
que la guerre en Ukraine le covid les
conviments successifs en Chine ont
ralenti toute la chaîne de production on
le voit dans toute l'industrie sauf
évidemment au niveau du médicament c'est
une dimension bien plus dramatique et
quand on voit que un traitement comme
liveboxysilline dont le coût est de
quelques euros donc le fabricant à une
marche qui est quasi nulle et il doit
faire face à une flambée des prix à une
flambée de ses coups de production et
donc dans les appels d'offres un moment
il a du mal à être le mieux 10 ans donc
il est pas obligatoirement servi en
premier c'est pour ça que depuis le
printemps le même alerte les pouvoirs
publics en disant il y a urgence pour
cette industrie d'avoir un plan d'action
inflation j'attends toujours la réponse
est-ce que ça veut dire Laurence haribet
et je reviens à la dimension européenne
vous avez commencé par là c'est à dire
que pour peser par exemple dans on peut
rester sur l'aboutissile la capacité à
peser sur une négociation pour être le
mieux 10 ans et obtenir les les produits
alors quand on est dans une phase de
pénurie c'est au niveau européen qu'on
doit pouvoir le faire est-ce que c'est
possible est-ce que c'est prévu tout
simplement pour nous c'est tout à fait
évident que de toute façon s'il y a une
stratégie une pharmaceutique à
développer et une politique de santé
publique même si les systèmes de santé
sont très différents et que l'Union
européenne a un problème de compétence
puisqu'elle n'a pas elle n'a qu'une
compétence coopération en matière de la
découverte
il y a la question il y a la question du
marché unique à la question de la
recherche ou là on a des compétences qui
sont des compétences beaucoup plus
pleines de l'Union européenne mais en
matière de politique de santé on est sur
une politique de coopération une peau de
ce qu'on appelle une une politique
d'appui mais il n'empêche que c'était
que la stratégie peut être développée au
niveau européen et moi je crois surtout
qu'il faut il faut changer de braquer et
de regard c'est à dire que on a une
industrie pharmaceutique qui est
mondialisée on a aujourd'hui des
spécialisations qui ont été plutôt
avec des avec des problèmes de pénurie
sur des sur des médicaments de base et
il faut avoir une stratégie qui est
différenciée selon les produits en
termes de stratégie pharmaceutique et
ensuite je pense qu'il faut aussi avoir
une approche de politique de santé enfin
moi c'est mon rôle en tant que en tant
que que parlementaire il faut aussi
avoir une politique de santé et de et de
prévisions qui soient une politique
territorialisée et donc avec ces deux
éléments là on peut aborder les choses
différemment Thierry juste une peut-être
une confirmation l'Observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament affirment que plus de 3000
médicaments sont aujourd'hui en forte
tension d'approvisionnement en France
est-ce que ce qu'ils sont dans le vrai
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
cette question ça concerne combien de
centaines ou de milliers de médicaments
il y a à peu près 12000 molécules
thérapeutiques en France 6000 ont été
déclarés d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeur
ce qui est aussi une source du problème
la moitié de la pharmacopée est
l'intérêt thérapeutique majeur donc on
risque de se diluer et pas mettre le de
se focaliser là où il faut qui sont sur
les molécules j'allais dire sanitaires
essentiel parce que s'il patiente l'a
pas il y a un risque vital ou un risque
de dégradation de sa maladie extrêmement
rapide et Madame assez matrice le disait
il y a une réflexion à l'échelle
européenne pour avoir cette liste qui
probablement serait d'un millier de
molécules et qu'il a nécessiterait une
vigilance particulière différemment sur
ces médicaments qui sont vraiment
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur pour vous
est-ce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont en
tension alors je sais pas si vous avez
la réponse peut-être que c'est une colle
et que personne ne peut y répondre je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas la réponse mais ce
que l'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y a
de nombreux médicaments et ça a augmenté
par rapport à l'an dernier qui sont en
tension que comme Madame le disait il y
a un instant le système qui a été mis en
place en France d'alerte de la NSM
permet au laboratoire de dialoguer avec
son autorité tutelle et de prendre des
mesures en amont quand on dit il y a une
tension il y a pas encore la rupture
donc on peut travailler ensemble pour la
gérer au mieux l'exemple type
c'est une obligation pour vous de faire
ces stocks alors il y a une est-ce que
c'est une obligation pour vous alors il
y a une obligation pour les molécules
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeures
d'avoir deux mois de stock et vous ne
les avez pas si on les a sur la plupart
des molécules on les a mais pas sur la
motricité mais
les pétroliers ils ont une obligation de
faire des stocks stratégiques il les
font mais vous savez vous ne faites pas
l'obligation qui
si vous avez votre stock de 2 mois c'est
justement pour avoir un effet tampon si
un moment ailleurs la demande augmente
si vous avez un problème industriel un
problème de qualité vous allez consommer
ce stock ce qu'on voit dans le cadre de
l'amoxicilline c'est que avec
l'augmentation de la demande mondiale le
stock a dû être consommé et l'idée a
priori sympathique de dire on a qu'à
stocker toutes les molécules en quantité
on n'aura pas de problème mais on va
créer un problème bien plus grave parce
qu'il y a une tension sur les
approvisionnements de matières premières
et on risque de faire des stocks de
molécules qui vont être dans un des
hangars climatisés avec tout l'impact
énergétique que l'on peut entendre en
consommant des matières premières qui
vont retarder la fabrication de
molécules essentielles donc le stock est
pas la solution magique la solution elle
est multifactorielle tu ne sais c'est
une des solutions mais ce n'est pas la
seule il n'y a pas une seule solution ça
fait un moment qu'on vous a pas entendu
que ça a marché veut dire que si la
France a de grosses difficultés ce
marché pharmaceutiques c'est
probablement que il y a des défaillances
dans son marché
on voit qu'il y a si on prend juste les
médicaments en tension il y en avait 400
à peu près pendant des années jusqu'aux
années 2017-2018 puis on est passé à
1500 en 2019 puis on est maintenant à
3000 donc on voit bien qu'il y a quand
même un phénomène pas de hasard mais
d'aggravation de la capacité à pouvoir
approvisionner le marché français alors
comme c'est un marché on peut peut-être
regarder sur la rentabilité du marché
c'est ce que j'allais vous demander
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est parce
que certains médicaments sont moins
intéressants d'autres quoi si vous
voulez encore le dernier projet de loi
de financement de sécurité sociale
puisqu'on a une régulation
essentiellement pris volumes que les
volumes augmentent tout le temps et
comme c'est très facile de pouvoir
garantir un budget à l'euro près
puisqu'on connaît relativement bien les
prévisions de volume on joue sur les
prix ça c'est le rabotage que l'on fait
depuis une quinzaine d'années d'ailleurs
qu'on a fait dans dans d'autres secteurs
comme l'hôpital comme on rabote on
rabote et puis il y a un moment où on
passe en dessous si vous voulez du seuil
du point mort du seuil de rentabilité
c'est pour ça que ça m'amuse histoire du
paracétamol puisque ça n'a aucune
viabilité économique puisque vous ne
pouvez pas avec les prix du paracétamol
en France rendent une production viable
mais comme c'est de l'argent public et
qu'on a mis 100 millions d'euros
d'argent public
UPSA et Sanofi ça les dérange pas trop
vous voyez mais quand même mais quand
même donc il y a une incohérence de
l'État en disant je veux redynamiser
l'industrie pharmaceutique en France la
relocaliser mais je ne donne pas les
prix qui permettent de la rendre
rentable il y a une incohérence
probablement des économistes aussi mais
des industriels autour du moins de ceux
qui les représentent en disant nous ce
que l'on veut limiter la progression
tout absolument en faisant le lobby qui
est nécessaire pour limiter la
progression des génériques qui sont
juste l'envers de la de la médaille de
l'innovation partout il y a de
l'innovation où il y a de la production
vous avez un marché du générique qui est
à plus de 80% en France il est à 40%.
parce que on essaye de d'empêcher ce
chercher là qui est ce qui vous donne la
ressource budgétaire pour financer
beaucoup mieux tarifer beaucoup mieux
les médicaments mais oui ça c'est quand
même le cœur du problème or on l'aborde
pas ce cœur là mais c'est ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'il y a une
responsabilité collective on peut pas
dire l'état l'État et puis en même temps
faire en sorte que on garde tous toutes
les rentes soit conservées dernier point
le paracétamol puisqu'on en parle c'est
la boxicilline ça c'est comme Madame
c'est la spécialiste un phénomène qui
est vraiment il est pas produit en
Europe c'est un phénomène qui est trop
européen le seul chose qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'on aurait pu anticiper parce
qu'on est dans un effet rebond des
pathologies infectieuses qui fait qu'on
aurait pu anticiper qu'on allait avoir
un besoin plus important bon enfin sinon
la France se retrouve au même note
c'est que le paracétamol n'est toujours
pas un produit considéré comme générique
c'est un produit qui a 60 ans pourquoi
parce qu'il fallait surtout protéger la
rente des laboratoires et donc on a
empêché la substitution de ce produit
dans la chose bon et pourquoi ça pose
problème ce qu'on pourrait se dire et
alors so what mais ça pose juste un
problème parce que une des façons de
garantir une bonne avant
d'approvisionnement des marchés c'est de
jouer sur la concurrence essayer de
permettre à l'ensemble des laboratoires
génériques de pouvoir produire ce qui
fait que quand vous avez plus d'acteurs
qui produisent si jamais il y en a un
qui a un problème vous en avez plus donc
oui si on avait ouvert au génériqueur ce
marché là parce qu'il aurait dû être le
cas et ça c'est une décision de l'État
enfin je veux dire il y a pas de sujets
donc oui voilà donc il faut que tout le
monde un petit peu et mais pour ça c'est
compliqué parce que dans quel contexte
c'est ce qu'on arrive à mettre tout le
monde autour de la tête c'est pas simple
mais c'est pas simple effectivement je
vais vous redonner la parole je voudrais
entendre rapidement Catherine Simonin
peut-être parce que je voyais faire
signe et vouloir intervenir sur plus
compliqué quand on est en duplex donc je
vais vous laisser répondre et puis
peut-être je vous pose une petite
question sur les on parle parce que vous
êtes la voix des malades il y a des ces
pénuries dont on parle il y a certains
traitements qui sont des traitements
lourds quoi il y a ce qu'on appelle une
perte de chance
oui absolument et il y a eu des pénuries
qui ont entraîné des pertes de chances
notamment dans le cancer de la vessie
avec le BCG intraveicical il était
produit en France par Sanofi
c'est pareil pour un GSK qui est en
Belgique et qui produisait des vaccins
contre les pattes qui a été en rupture
pendant 2 ans et demi et évidemment
quand vous avez pas le médicament pour
soigner votre cancer il y a une
substitution voire une pénurie sèche et
pas de substitution possible et là ça
met en péril l'avenir des personnes et
tout ça bien sûr n'est pas suivi dans le
plan de lutte contre les pénuries il y
avait un axe 2 justement pour suivre ces
personnes qui avaient des ruptures dans
leur médicament et de savoir ce qu'il
devenait alors effectivement je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur bizarre la
solution n'est pas de recentrer la
production en Europe sur un seul
producteur mais bien de diversifier tout
l'approvisionnement de la chaîne parce
qu'autrement on ne sera vraiment pas
s'il y a un en dans la production de
cette usine on sera dans la même
situation qu'aujourd'hui
d'autre part il y a aussi de des prix de
l'innovation qui s'envolent et c'est un
véritable enjeu que les industriels
arrêtent la production d'anciennes
molécules pour se diversifier plutôt
vers l'innovation qui est très rentable
et de plus en plus rentable et sans
avoir vraiment des progrès majeurs avec
ces nouveaux médicaments et qui ne
s'adressent pas à un public large donc
l'article 30 notamment du PLFSS 2023 il
y avait un sous-article qui quand un
industriel venait chercher un prix pour
une innovation on revisité son catalogue
et on l'obligeait à garder
contractuellement son vieux médicament
et effectivement c'était un enjeu qui
pouvait lutter également contre les
pénuries et ensuite oui les deux mois de
stock sont une obligation réglementaire
mais pour ceux qui ont été en pénurie
derrière on est deux années précédentes
c'est 421 MTM les médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur c'est quatre mois
de stock obligatoire sachant qu'une
pénurie de médicaments en moyenne c'est
3 mois et demi pour les médicaments qui
sont en pénurie et ensuite je voudrais
dire que effectivement quand on produit
un médicament il y a d'énormes sociales
des normes environnementales à respecter
et en tant que patient on aimerait bien
avoir
compter de la transparence sur les
approvisionnements et d'où viennent les
produits comment ils sont produits
est-ce qu'ils respectent l'environnement
est-ce qu'il respecte l'énorme sociale
pour les travailleurs qui le produisent
est-ce que ces personnes sont exposées à
certains risques pour leur santé c'est
tout l'enjeu de demain et je crois
qu'effectivement il faut réfléchir à
rendre cette production plus noble en
sens de l'environnement et de du social
dans nos interrompre merci Catherine
Simona mais le temps file vraiment très
vite il nous reste 12 minutes Mathieu je
voudrais qu'on parle de ce mot de
souveraineté vous êtes intéressé à
l'émergence de ce concept dans le débat
public parce que je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais ils n'ont plus que ce
mot à la bouche souvent de tes parties
souvent de tes par là écoutez
décarbonation de notre industrie c'est
un des éléments qui doit nous permettre
de continuer à créer de l'emploi
industriel consolider les grands
champions permettent de créer davantage
de startups d'accompagner les
changements d'usage de renforcer notre
souveraineté mais en baissant nos
émissions pour qu'on puisse les
exploiter et qu'on donne de la
visibilité sur le long terme il faut
qu'on développe aussi le recyclage qui
permettra d'améliorer notre souveraineté
en la matière il en va de notre
transition écologique il en va de notre
souveraineté il en va de notre pouvoir
d'achat bon alors c'est une petite
révolution car il y a encore quelques
années le terme serait passé pour un
gros mot tant il était associé à son
cousin le souveraineté ce qu'est le
souverainisme ça fait son apparition
dans le débat politique français la fin
des années 90 c'est résolument ancré
dans le débat pro ou anti-européen sauf
que précisément les entiers en ont marre
de passer pour des opposants et donc ils
inventent ce concept qu'ils estiment
positif le souverainisme le
souverainisme s'entend à l'époque comme
une alternative à la construction
européenne telle qu'elle s'est engagée
et souverainiste en gros pour celui qui
refuse de transférer l'exercice d'un
pouvoir généralement régalien a une
autorité supranationale en l'occurrence
l'Europe le terme is fleur bon histoire
de France souverain souverainisme et il
se double vite ne sont pas dans
économiques le protectionnisme car on
trouve donc chez les souverainistes des
opposants à l'ouverture des frontières
et comme des opposants à la des
adversaires de la mondialisation ce qui
explique d'ailleurs que le concept fera
Flores d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier politique car s'il est bien
né à droite ce concept de souverainisme
et qui s'est développé autour de parti
comme le MPF de Philippe de Villiers
debout la France de Nicolas dupontaignan
encore l'effet mère RPF de Charles
Pasqua et bien il trouve des porte-voix
à gauche opposées au libre-échange que
ce soit et Jean-Pierre Chevènement un
Montebourg ou dans une certaine mesure
même Jean-Luc Mélenchon et alors quand
est-ce qu'on passe du souverainisme à la
souveraineté 20 ans plus tard à la fin
des années 2010 et avec la crise covid
notamment qui remet au premier plan la
question de nos intérêts vitaux de nos
intérêts nationaux la France des cours
et Farid on en a parlé des pénuries de
masques les pénuries de paracétamol plus
de vaccins c'est leur du sauf qui peut
et d'une prise de cons l'heure n'est
plus un état qui se concentre ou qui se
contente de son rôle de stratège mais au
retour de l'État qui protège et du coup
la question de la souveraineté devient
la pierre angulaire de la politique
économique pas sous l'angle de
l'autarcie parce que tout le monde a
bien compris que la France ne pouvait se
suffire elle-même mais sous l'angle de
l'indépendance pas forcément un échelle
nationale mais à l'échelle européenne et
du coup la souveraineté se décline à
toutes les sources depuis souvent été
sanitaires on en parle ici souvent une
telle alimentaire énergétique ce qui
explique entre nous le virage à 180
degrés sur le nucléaire souveraineté
numérique aussi et bien sûr depuis la
guerre en Ukraine souveraineté
stratégique ou souveraineté militaire en
gros pour assurer son avenir face au
désordre du monde mais la France et
l'Europe doivent reprendre à leur destin
est-ce que c'est une belle revanche pour
les aussi
c'est que cette époque marque la fin des
rêves souverainiste d'origine plus
personne ou presque ne prône la sortie
de l'euro ou de l'Europe le brexit est
passé par là mais voilà la souveraineté
elle s'est répandue dans tous les champs
du débat public et alors c'est c'est
intéressant alors parce que maintenant
le souverainisme il est europ alors que
il est il est né ce que non la
souveraineté d'une certaine façon parce
que il y a cet enjeu de souveraineté qui
est devenu européen non parce que je
pense que quand on parle de souveraineté
européenne on parle pas de renfermement
de l'Europe sur elle-même non plus parce
que l'Europe elle est inscrite c'est
quand même une question si on met une si
on met une taxe sur les sur les
véhicules électriques qui arrivent
d'Asie c'est une forme de protection
mais oui mais protectionnisme et
souverainiste c'est pas tout à fait non
plus la même chose donc bon moi ça me
fait c'est c'est intéressant ce que mais
ça me fait sourire parce que
l'utilisation des mots comme ça à
travers les années
ça aussi ça a l'air de c'est du domaine
du symbolique et du domaine de la
stratégie politique quelque part et on
voit bien pourquoi on parle de
souveraineté aujourd'hui et vous l'avez
très bien très bien expliqué donc je
pense que en plus ça a pas beaucoup de
sens parce que là souveraineté c'est
liée à la nation donc parler de
souveraineté européenne c'est quelque
part un peu cocasse mais bon moi je
m'arrête pas à ça ce que je ce qui me
semble important et c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de démontrer dans le travail
qu'on fait avec avec Pascal grenier
c'est que c'est qu'en fait les solutions
sont pas des solutions nationales les
solutions elles sont elles sont
essentiellement au niveau européen mais
ce sont des solutions qui sont aussi
ancrées au territoire et il a quelque
chose par contre qui qui est pas qui est
pas inintéressant c'est à dire cette de
concevoir l'ouverture européenne non pas
comme une dilution mais comme en fait un
recentrage sur les territoires Mathieu
très vite
est-ce que sur les boîtes de médicaments
il y a marqué fabriquer en Chine par
exemple
je crois qu'il y a le lieu de
fabrication le lieu du site qui est
enregistré c'est un peu ces
techniquement très complexe on pourrait
revenir sur l'information qui est sur
les boîtes de médicaments qui est très
complexe mais je voudrais revenir sur
deux points très vite très vite ce que
j'ai encore une autre chronique sur le
est-ce qu'il faut créer un secteur
public du médicament oui voilà donc
allez-y rentre de situation la moitié
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui
opèrent en France sont des PME qui font
moins de 10 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires qui sont pas
non mais qui sont pas du tout c'est la
moitié des labos implantés en France qui
sont pas du tout en situation de rente
de en situation de rente et je vais vous
donner un exemple quand au basket il
fait extrêmement concret quand on parle
du risque de pénurie qui est devant nous
on a tous un moment été à l'hôpital dans
notre vie
généralement un moment on a une
perfusion et pour administrer le
médicament faut un diluant généralement
c'est du bicarbonate de sodium
produit de base pour n'importe quel
intervention à l'hôpital
le flacon d'un millilitre il est vendu
un euro 40 il y a 10 ans en arrière le
fabricant français il faisait 14
centimes de marge aujourd'hui il en fait
17 centimes de pertes demain il finira
par ne plus pouvoir continuer à produire
et on sera dépendant d'approvisionnement
extraterritoriaux il faudra faire des
appels d'offres qui nous coûteront une
fortune aura des aura détruit une usine
on aura détruit de l'emploi le challenge
il est là aujourd'hui c'est où les
secteurs économiques ont les moyens
je suis obligé de reprendre la machine
on n'aura pas le temps de parler du
service public
nous nous rejoindre faut-il créer un
pôle public du médicament les les
sénateurs communistes le demandait il y
a deux ans évidemment en pleine épidémie
de covid oui c'était en décembre 2020
alors que le nombre de ruptures de
stocks de médicaments ne cessaient
d'augmenter en France le groupe
communiste avait déposé une proposition
de loi à l'initiative notamment de
Laurence Cohen la sénatrice du
Val-de-Marne je vous propose de la
réécouter
nous assistons un des manques des
pénuries de médicaments et au fait que
l'État n'a absolument pas la maîtrise de
la production de la fabrication des
médicaments pratiquement la majorité de
la production se fait en dehors du
territoire national donc cet outil là
c'est également pour que la France
retrouve sa souveraineté une question de
souveraineté encore le texte visait donc
à créer un pôle public du médicament et
des produits médicaux une demande des
communistes depuis une quinzaine
d'années concrètement cette structure
s'appuierait sur les pharmacies
centrales des armées et de l'AP-HP et
elle pourrait permettre la réquisition
des laboratoires privés du médicament
sont financement lui serait assuré par
une taxe de 1% sur le chiffre d'affaires
des entreprises pharmaceutiques un pôle
qui ne viserait pas à produire
l'intégralité des médicaments
disponibles sur le marché en France mais
seulement vous en parlez tout à l'heure
les médicaments d'intérêt petit à savoir
les médicaments cardiovasculaires
anti-infectieux anticancéreux alors elle
est devenue quoi cette proposition de
loi et bien elle a été rejetée par le
Sénat le 9 décembre 2020 surtout elle
n'avait pas fait l'unanimité à gauche
certains sénateurs mettaient en cause le
périmètre d'action trop limité de ce
pôle public et souhaité la création d'un
pôle du médicament et bien au niveau
européen mais cette proposition a quand
même été reprise lors de la campagne
présidentielle par certains candidats
Jean-Luc Mélenchon par exemple mais
aussi le candidat à communiste Fabien
Roussel on peut le réécouter ils ont été
les logiques des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques c'est de produire des
médicaments qui rapportent
et d'abandonner ce qui coûte moi je suis
pour justement dans un pôle public nous
puissions produire ensemble avec une
maîtrise de l'État avec un participation
de l'État dans l'actionnariat de ces
groupes
pour faire en sorte que ce qui rapporte
à tous et que ça finance ce qui coûte un
exemple plus récent c'est la demande
d'un pôle public du médicament figuré
dans la motion de censure déposer 7
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale par le
groupe de la France insoumise merci
Jérémie je reviens donc vers vous
Fédéric bizarre est-ce que les tasses
saurai faire vous voyez ce que je veux
dire alors d'abord ce ne souveraineté
sans trop l'intellectualisé elle est
quand même importante à analyser ces
gens Bodin c'est au XVIème siècle un peu
initié ça Jean Bodin Thomas Hobbes c'est
une notion de pouvoir d'accord c'est de
pouvoir de l'État parler de pouvoir
absolu et permanent qui est maintenant
avec la démocratie le souverain c'est
l'individu c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on est passé du souverainiste pas à
rien mais beaucoup plus parce qu'en fait
on donne tout pouvoir l'individu on
considère que c'est lui qui a
strictement tout pouvoir et que l'État
finalement démonétise l'état de la
capacité d'agir alors je reviens sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique et à quoi ça
on aura pas le temps de parler du pôle
public si vous faites ça si mais le pôle
j'ai fini par le pôle public parce que
c'est une idée intéressante
intellectuellement même si elle est
inapplicable ou tout du moins sauf à une
évolution importante on voit la dépense
fixe mais elle est elle est intéressante
intellectuellement elle est un peu
radicale ça correspond à quoi la
souveraineté pharmaceutique à ce que
l'État reprenne un peu le pouvoir de
contrôle pas le pouvoir absolu en étant
le propriétaire forcément des usines
mais le pouvoir pour l'intérêt général
la notion de souveraineté c'est lié à
l'intérêt général et permet qu'on ait un
approvisionnement suffisant que la
France soit un pays qui dispose de
toutes les innovations bon donc là à
partir du moment où vous avez un
industrie qui est complètement
mondialisé qui échappe complètement aux
États avec des financements mondialisés
et ce qui s'est passé pour réduire les
coûts une production dans les produits à
base il faut récupérer un peu le
contrôle de tout ça donc on a mis deux
mois de stock tout ça enfin tout ça
c'est peanuts par rapport à ce qu'il
faut et c'est là où je pense qu'il faut
véritablement et il faut que les
industriels évidemment si mais l'idée
c'est de pas de punir de sanctionner
certainement pas c'est d'être le plus
efficace possible donc d'impliquer je
sais pas si c'est à des Assises de la
souveraineté mais il y a quand même une
réflexion de fond avoir comment est-ce
que l'État peut là pour le coup inciter
très fortement pour pas parler d'imposer
à ce que les industriels garantissent la
bonne fourniture des médicaments à des
coûts raisonnables deuxième chose sur le
le donc le pour parler de du pôle public
évidemment les communistes disent toute
façon faut pas faire confiance au marché
ils ont pas entièrement tort pour ça sur
le fait qu'on a problème beaucoup trop
libéralisé l'industrie pharmaceutique
historiquement et le marché n'est pas un
bon régulateur pour garantir l'intérêt
général en santé ça on le savait mais
par contre c'est sûr que le secteur
privé est plus efficace que le secteur
public pour innover et pour produire à
bas coût vous voyez donc c'est pas pour
ça qu'il faut ramener tout dans le giron
public mais là où les communistes ont
raison c'est qu'il faut que l'État
reprenne la main sur les parce que c'est
l'argent public tout ça sur les
contreparties à ce financement
financiariser juste le dernier point
c'est terminé bon mais il faut bien
comprendre que la France a fait de ce
marché pharmaceutique un marché de rente
parce que nous ne sommes pas nous sommes
faibles sur l'innovation et nous sommes
faits pour les génériques merci pour
changer pardon de ne pas vous donner la
parole pour répondre sur cette partie et
l'opérateur public ne frappe mieux que
le complot ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que le moyen de gamme est trop
fort on n'a pas le temps favoriser on a
entendu l'opérateur public ne fera pas
mieux que l'opérateur privé c'est ce que
vous lui dit vous savez quoi ça va
continuer après le générique merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis à demain dans ce sens public et
puis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique
Oriane Mancini qui reçoit Mickael de la
fosse le maire de Montpellier c'est à 8
heures demain matin salut
[Musique]